امام القياده العامه الرئيسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم باجازه من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد اسبوع من الاشتباكات
في السودان في الجيش يعلنوا موافقته على
هدنه مدتها ثلاثه ايام في عيد الفطر وينشر
الافا من افراده في الخرطوم لمطارده ما
وصفها ببئر الجماعات المتمرده والمستشار
القانوني لقوات الدعم السريع يقول للجزيره
انها ما تزال تسيطر على مواقعها السابقه
وتوسع نطاقها وعلى الصعيد الانساني وزير
التنميه الاجتماعيه السودانيه يقول
للجزيره ان العديد من السلع نفدت من
المتاجر بسبب ضعف الامداد نقابه الاطباء
تحذر من مزيد من الانهيار في القطاع الصحي
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه تعلن ارتفاع عدد
قتل الاشتباكات الى اكثر من 400 المسلمون
في اغلب الدول العربيه والاسلاميه يحتفلون
باول ايام عيد الفطر المبارك متبادرين
التهاني والاحتفاء باتمام صيام رمضان وفي
السودان اقام عدد من السكان صلاه العيد في
ظل اجواء من الخوف والقلق بسبب العمليات
العسكريه الدائره داعين الى وقف الاقتتال
وتجنيب البلاد حربا اهليه تويتر تبدا في
ازاله العلامه الزرقاء من حسابات
مستخدميها الذين لم يدفعوا مقابل توثيقها
ما ادى الى فقدان مشاهير لعلامات توثيق
حساباتهم مثل نجم كره القدم كريستيانو
رونالدو وايقونه
لانهم لم يدفعوا ثمن الاشتراك الشهري لقاء
الاحتفاظ بها الى اللقاء